[Musique]
avec annie nous sommes très heureux à
notre tour de vous souhaiter la
bienvenue ici au port marly
je vais demander à geoffroy bac de
keating rdj des yvelines de nous
rejoindre avec marie glinel responsable
des jeunes adjoint de la haute garonne
va lapin ou fiac pour paris et élise des
moulins responsable départemental de la
jeunesse de la marne c'est bon tout le
monde est là après quelques mots
d'introduction après ces quatre tables
rondes auxquelles vous avez pu
participer d'abord vous dire et je suis
très heureux de me retrouver de faire
équipe avec annie sur scène cet après
midi d'hier d'abord à christian un
immense merci parce que il y a un an
tu t'es engagé avec l'ensemble de tes
équipes de nos équipes a organisé ce
premier grand rendez vous de la jeunesse
la promesse est tenue et aujourd'hui
aucun autre parti politique aucun autre
n'est capable de rassembler plus de 1000
jeunes pendant deux jours pour débattre
pas simplement pour faire la fête pas
simplement pour le plaisir de se
retrouver
mais pour faire un immense travail de
fond parce que ceux qui mènent le monde
nous le savons n'en déplaise à quelques
esprits chagrins qui n'ont que la
présidentielle à la babine ce qui fonde
l'engagement politique
ce qui mène le monde ce sont les idées
il n'y a pas de victoire électorale sans
victoire idéologique c'est à dire sans
démontrer à nos compatriotes ce que nous
avons à leur dire
et ce en quoi nous croyons et christian
jacob avec aurélien pradié avec toute
notre équipe dirigeante
christian a souhaité fonder cet
événement sur deux piliers le pilier
d'abord de la jeunesse dont vous êtes
les représentants
il y a deux manières de s'adresser à la
jeunesse il y à là manière très
conformiste qui est de vous promettre
l'esprit de défaite vous promettre le
rsa des contrats au rabais des minima
sociaux
comme si on pouvait faire croire la
jeunesse de france que l'on pouvait
grandir sans effort et sans travail
et puis ils allaient me à la manière de
notre famille politique de la famille
gaulliste qui est de rappeler que la
jeunesse est une promesse d'émancipation
par le travail par l'autonomie par
l'effort par la dignité et notre
objectif collectif ici cet après midi
n'est pas de dire que la jeunesse c'est
le prolongement éternelle et indéfinie
de l'enfance la jeunesse
notre objectif à nous les républicains
c'est de vous permettre un jour de
devenir adulte pour pouvoir accomplir
vos rêves de jeunesse sans jamais
renoncer à vos rêves d'absolu c'est une
différence majeure entre notre famille
politique et tous les autres et puis le
deuxième pilier ce sont les idées alors
dans le monde politique et médiatique
actuel c'est pas forcément à la mode les
idées on préfère la politique du tweet
de la communication du bavardage de
l'immédiateté et pourtant cet immense
travail de fond le dernier d'ailleurs
qu'il a mené en 2005 2006 c'était
nicolas sarkozy
il est indispensable à notre famille
politique et les idées c'est notre socle
commun ce sont nos fondations
il n'y a pas de politique sans
conviction sans valeur sans idées est
celui qui le rappelle magnifiquement je
lisais c'est aurélien pradié qu'il
racontait je crois dans une interview
cet été je sais car certains d'entre
vous pour en avoir parlé avec voulons
lui j'ai comme certains d'entre vous
passez m'ont été avec omer ce magnifique
livre de sylvain tesson et sylvain
tesson raconte combien à travers ulysse
à travers l'odyssée il y a trois mille
ans
les démocraties se sont fondés
progressivement sur les idées c'est à
dire sur le fait de savoir d'où nous
venons et ce en quoi nous croyons la
véritable géographie homérique son
architecture c'est la patrie c'est le
royaume c'est le fief c'est le foyer
personne ne peut être fier de son propre
reflet s'il ne peut pas se prétendre de
quelque part s'il ne peut pas
revendiquer un port d'attache et bien
aujourd'hui notre port d'attaché port
marly et ce quelque part c'est la france
qui nous conduit nous les républicains à
considérer est apportée aux yeux du
monde et aux yeux de la france une
certaine idée de la france c'est tout ce
combat pour les idées que nous allons
mener collectivement ensemble tout au
long de ces deux jours et pour les mois
qui viennent merci guillaume bonjour à
tous tout d'abord merci de votre
présence nombreuse
vous le savez faire le choix de la
jeunesse pour ouvrir cette rentrée
politique
c'est un choix extrêmement fort et vous
avez répondu nombreux grâce à la
mobilisation des rdj que je veux saluer
et remercier grâce aussi à la
mobilisation des équipes de notre parti
politique est donc pour nous c'est
vraiment un signal très fort que nous
voulons donner non seulement la jeunesse
mais à l'ensemble des français c'est un
signal d'optimisme et de foi en l'avenir
vous avez participé à quatre ateliers
dans un exercice qui n'est pas facile on
s'y est déjà prêté on sait qu'être
rapporteur d'une table ronde ça n'est
pas simple d'autant que l'exercice
auquel nous vous avons invités était de
laisser libre cours à vos propositions à
vos idées à vos suggestions n'y avait
pas de canevas il n'y avait pas
d'exercice contre 1 c'était vraiment un
exercice où vous étiez invité à vous
exprimer de la façon la plus spontanée
la plus libre possible
donc je voudrais tout d'abord remercier
nos quatre rapporteurs qui ont accepté
de se prêter à cet exercice exigeant
mais je ne veux pas leur maître
la pression parce que leur sujet va être
finalement de restituer ce qui s'est dit
donc vous n'avez pas en endosser la
responsabilité
vous devez simplement être le plus
fidèle possible à ce qui s'est dit alors
le moment est venu pour vous chers amis
d'entendre cette restitution avec nos
quatre rapporteurs geoffroy et permettez
moi de rappeler les sujets des quatre
ateliers geoffroy qui va rapporter
l'atelier réconcilier croissance et
écologie marie qui va rapporter
l'atelier réconciliée démocratie
autorités valentin réconcilier réussite
et république et élise réconcilier
europe et souveraineté et en écrivant ce
petit mémo ce petit rappel il ya un mot
qui m'a sauté aux yeux
cet idiot mais quand j'ai lu le
programme comme chacun d'entre vous et
ils ne mettaient pas apparue aussi
nettement que lorsque j'en ai pris
quelques notes c'est le terme de
réconcilier la réflexion à laquelle nous
vous avons invités aujourd'hui est
placée sous le signe de la
réconciliation devrait la réconciliation
de notions qui aujourd'hui s'opposent et
traduisent toutes les fractures qui
divise notre pays et les républicains se
propose d'être précisément s'efforce de
réconciliation de clivage qui
aujourd'hui stérilise la pensée et
empêchent d'agir non pas par un
consensus mou qui donne raison aux uns
et un peu aux autres ça c'est là en même
temps macro niant ce n'est pas
évidemment la démarche à laquelle nous
vous invitons nous voulons au contraire
sur l'écologie sur l'autorité sur la
réussite sur l'europe la souveraineté
dégager une dialectique une dynamique et
c'est à cela que chacun des groupes a
été invité à réfléchir
alors maintenant la parole est à eux et
je pense qu'on commence dans l'ordre des
ateliers font ça j'ai pas
j'ai pas vérifié mais on commence par
l'atelier numéro 1 croissance et
écologie c'est bien ça c'est moi c'est
toi voilà bon merci bonjour à tous donc
on a eu un échange qui était
particulièrement fructueux riche
intéressant malheureusement une heure et
demie c'était presque trop court on
aurait pu en parler
toute la journée donc on va prolonger
ces échanges demain on a nourri une
réflexion qui était vraiment
intéressante et qui j'ai vu donc député
damien abad qui étaient présents dans la
salle qui assistent aux échanges et je
suis sûr qu'il prolongera c'est cette
réflexion demain donc globalement on a
on a beaucoup beaucoup discuté
on a d'abord remis en perspective cet
héritage de la droite sur
l'environnement parce que contrairement
à ce que l'on pense c'est la droite qui
a fait les plus grandes avancées sur
l'environnement on a d'abord eu pompidou
qui a fait le premier ministre de
l'environnement on à chirac qui a
inscrit la protection de l'environnement
dans la constitution sarkozy premier
grenelle de l'environnement donc
vraiment on n'a pas à avoir honte de se
passer sur notre action environnementale
mais aujourd'hui il faut aller encore
plus loin et tout le but de cet atelier
concilier écologie et croissance avait
pour but de voir à l'avenir on n'a pas
besoin peut-être de haut commissaire au
plan pour réfléchir à l'avenir mais
plutôt de repartir de nos ateliers
repartir des militants des adhérents et
surtout de la jeunesse qui a un message
à porter sur ce sujet la jeunesse on en
parle tout le temps
on dit toujours que elle veut
qu'on avance sur la croissance
écologique elle veut que l'on protège
l'environnement mais on interroge
toujours les mêmes personnes l'entourage
autour des personnes qui vont voilà qui
des greta d'autres qui vont vous dire
que il faut arrêter de consommer il faut
revenir à cheval et c'est la meilleure
manière de d'arrêter la pollution donc
nous si ça a été aussi riche c'est parce
que on a une jeunesse de droite qui
avait un discours à l'encontre de cela
et qui disait justement que l'urgence
climatique ne doit pas se faire au
détriment de l'urgence économique aussi
puisqu'on l'a vu avec le co vide
beaucoup d'entreprises sont en
difficulté et qui sont les premiers à
pâtir de cette urgence économique ce
sont les jeunes qui subissent un chômage
un chômage de masse
donc c'est vraiment important de
remettre ces deux urgences en
perspective pour les concilier alors
globalement on a parlé de beaucoup de
sujets le premier sujet qui est revenu
c'est l'alimentation l'alimentation
l'agriculture et la ruralité qui a
suscité beaucoup des changes
globalement on sent une jeunesse alerte
sur l'alimentation beaucoup de
proposition pour investir dans
l'accompagnement de nos agriculteurs
pour une vraie transition écologique
c'est surtout leur donner la liberté la
liberté d'innover de d'innover dans
leurs moyens de production pour
améliorer leur production être plus
économe plus de sobriété
voilà sur l'alimentation on a parlé d'
aménagement du territoire puisque je ne
saurais dire qui avait dit cela mais on
a pendant des années dit que pour
préserver l'environnement il fallait en
passer tout le monde dans des
habitations d'avoir une forte densité
pour préserver nos espaces naturels
mais à l'inversé que désormais
maintenant tous les habitants nous
rejette ou les cette population condensé
nous demandent de l'environnement de
demandes de la nature et demandent à
avoir ces espaces de respiration
donc voilà la contradiction qui a été
soulevé et qui aujourd'hui peut-être
c'est une réflexion qu'il faut entamer
c'est cet aménagement du territoire qui
évidemment ne manquera pas de faire
avancer la droite dans les années qui
viennent
on a également réinterroger la notion de
croissance qu'est ce que la croissance
enrichissement la création de valeur
ajoutée la création de richesses mais la
création de richesses dans quoi quelle
valeur ajoutée ou est ce qu'on la met
cette valeur ajoutée ou est-ce qu'on
investit et donc évidemment on est
revenu à cette croissance écologique de
dire qu'il fallait vraiment investir
dans cette innovation et puis on a une
formidable jeunesse une génération
aujourd'hui qui est très engagé sur ces
sujets là et qui résout sans cesse des
problèmes que l'on avait notamment sur
les emballages plastique par exemple
donc c'est vraiment cette jeunesse qui
est alerte sur les sujets
d'environnement qui a les clés et qu'ils
se bougent aujourd'hui pour améliorer
nos industries voilà globalement on a
parlé de fiscalité la fiscalité
puisque on a parlé de traité de libre
échange en disant qu'on importait des
produits qui ne respectaient pas les
normes que l'on imposé à nos industries
à noah
sculpteur cette fiscalité on s'est
traité de libre-échange pardon ces
traités de libre échange
on disait qu'on n'était pas assez
compétitif par rapport aux personnes aux
autres pays notamment le canada alors
quelqu'un avait répondu que c'était
probablement par rapport à notre
fiscalité puisque la main d'oeuvre
canadienne était au même niveau que la
main d'oeuvre française et que c'était
surtout cette fiscalité qui nous
permettrait d'avoir aussi plus de
compétitivité par rapport aux autres
pays et que dès lors et bien nous
pourrions avoir une industrie plus
puissante relocaliser nos emplois
consommez local moins de deux produits
carbonés voilà et puis on a parlé
2 oui donc je disais juste sur cette
notion de croissance
c'était particulièrement intéressant
puisque les jeunes qui étaient présents
dans la salle en était à se demander
voilà est-ce qu'il faut de la
décroissance pas de décroissance se
demandait vraiment qu'elle est où là où
l'innovation devait aller est ce que
l'innovation devait servir à
sancerre a sans cesse faire plus de
croissance ou bien à aller dans un
projet un projet humain que nous avions
et tout cela c'est quelque chose que
nous devons définir ensemble ou ou
investissons nous mettons nous
l'investissement dans la recherche et
comment on construit un projet tous
ensemble qui fait sens pour tous les
français et pour toute la jeunesse de
france
voilà merci merci je ferais je voudrais
te remercier geoffroy d'avoir rappelé ce
que notre famille politique à apporter à
la question écologique parce que il faut
bien reconnaître que cette question elle
s'impose dans le débat national et en
particulier chez les jeunes d'ailleurs
tu tu va frôler la question en disant on
s'interroge de savoir s'il faut de la
croissance ou pas est ce que la
croissance a un sens je crois que cette
question elle traverse non seulement la
jeunesse mais mais aussi toute la
société et il faut le dire aussi
notre famille politique a laissé de côté
ses thématiques et d'autres gens sont
emparés mais d'autres sources on a paré
pour en faire quelque chose de
préjudiciable non seulement à notre pays
mais même à la question écologique elle
même j'évoquerai la fermeture de
fessenheim a le député raphael jeune
berger parmi nous aujourd'hui c'est
l'énergie la plus décarbonés qui soit et
donc on voit bien que cette question
écologique elle traverse aujourd'hui il
faut pas la prendre à la légère
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
on en a fait un des quatre thèmes de
réflexion de cet après-midi parce que ce
que nous voulons c'est nous situer
ailleurs que dans le radicalisme verts
qui a quand même fait des ravages au
niveau électoral on a vu des grandes
villes tombées aux mains des verts c'est
un fait politique majeur et se situer
aussi ailleurs que dans la complaisance
à laquelle se livre la macro ni qui
donnent tantôt raison aux uns tantôt
raison aux autres et empêche d'avoir une
ligne claire sur ces sujets fondamentaux
donc je crois comme tu l'as dit
la droite a effectivement une partie
capitale à jouer non seulement sur le
plan politique mais sur le plan de
l'avenir de notre pays
alors moi j'ai une question à poser
geoffroy il fut un temps où le progrès
était espéré ou le progrès était
valorisée ou le progrès était quelque
chose d'attendu est de plus en plus
aujourd'hui on voit le progrès remis en
cause je prendrai un exemple la 5g la 5g
qui est un élément capital pour la
compétitivité de notre économie est ce
que tu as le sentiment dans les
fréquentations qui sont les tiennes dans
les discussions tu peux avoir avec tes
amis que cette méfiance à l'égard du
progrès elle prospère où contraire notre
famille politique incarne la foi dans le
progrès alors je crois qu'on a beaucoup
mélanger les sujets c'est vrai que quand
on dit on a parlé de progrès aujourd'hui
beaucoup de jeunes se disent que le
progrès c'est mal voilà parce que on a
notamment dans l'agriculture on a mis
des produits donc des produits
phytosanitaires on a dit que c'était mal
alors qu'on n'a jamais autant consommé
le médicament
les humains n'ont jamais autant consommé
donc en fait qu'elle ait calé cette
notion de progrès qu'est ce que ça veut
dire que le progrès et je le dis encore
ou où nous mène-t-il on peut faire du on
peut avoir du progrès technique
mais encore faut-il qu'ils servent un
projet voilà donc beaucoup de jeunes
nous voilà avait sept cette question sur
sur le progrès mais je crois qu'il faut
justement vendre le progrès le progrès
il a permis d'améliorer des conditions
les conditions de vie des sur ces
dernières décennies on n'a jamais aussi
bien vécu que sur c'est sur cette
dernière décennie
donc le progrès ne va pas à l'encontre
de l'homme justement et il faut plutôt
le valoriser ce progrès et se pourrait
il faut le met au service de justement
l'écologie j'ai on a parlé un moment de
sobriété
on n'a pas eu de sobriété dans notre
dans notre atelier et je crois que le
progrès peut-être doit être au service
de cette sobriété
c'est à dire comme nous l'avons dit des
outils qui consomme moins d'énergie
si on fait du progrès dans les batteries
pour le recyclage
enfin c'est ce sont vraiment des choses
qui sont plutôt bénéfique
le progrès est au service justement de
l'homme voilà et qui sont concrètes
on n'est pas dans l'idéologie on est
dans le nom n'est pas dans l'idéologie
il suffit pas de dire arrêtons tout on
n'arrivera pas demain en fait la
question
on a demandé qui se passerait de son
téléphone portable personne voilà
personne ne se passerait de son
smartphone donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
arrêter d'être dans l'idéologie
il faut être dans le concret et
maintenant comment on fait pour que les
composants par exemple d'un téléphone
portable soit plus écologique
c'est un exemple merci je froid merci à
vous
guillaume la gouaille et numéro 2 oui
l'écologie mais mieux que les verts
d'extrême gauche donc merci beaucoup de
nous avoir tracé de cette perspective
alors chère marie toi tu avais le
l'immense plaisir d'accompagner notre
ami gilles platret et nos parlementaires
et les grands élus sur une question
centrale est fondatrice de notre famille
politique et de notre république qui est
l'autorité et le rapport de nos
compatriotes aux questions de sécurité
alors comment tu aperçu cette cette
table ronde et qu'est-ce que tu en as
retenu dans l'est dans les grandes
lignes
merci beaucoup alors justement quand
j'entends le rapport de jofra sur la
question de l'écologie je me rends
compte que le fait que l'autorité soit
un sujet fondamental fondateur est
fondamental de notre famille politique
nous empêche véritablement de prendre du
recul sur lui et c'est ça que j'ai pu
peut-être percevoir aujourd'hui
contrairement du coup à la question de
l'écologie qui manifestement a suscité
de vives passions et de vives critiques
finalement on a on peut construire un
véritable discours sur un sujet sur
lequel on n'a pas vraiment beaucoup
parler ouais et donc sur la question de
l'autorité
on se rend compte que nous avons quand
même un discours extrêmement rodez
peut-être le mieux rodé de tous les
partis politiques puisque c'est un sujet
que nous connaissons bien et en fait
finalement à droite oui nous aimons
l'autorité mais nous nous posons pas la
question de savoir pourquoi nous
l'aimons cette autorité est elle
véritablement indispensable si nous
étions dans un état un peu plus
tranquille qui en a moins besoin
donc en fait c'est pas vraiment l'amour
de l'autorité qu'on doit vraiment
discuter mais plutôt le besoin
d'autorité et la démocratie et elle a
finalement dans le sujet de
réconciliation la démocratie aurait pu
être là justement pour apporter cette
touche de fraîcheur
cette fraîcheur par des mots et
expressions aurait pu apporter cette cet
élan finalement de ressources et de
solutions bon alors c'est juste ça que
j'ai trouvé un peu manquant finalement
dans dans les questions qui étaient
posées
finalement c'est ça qu'on encore porte
c'est donc le fait que la démocratie ait
été complètement mise de cossette mise
de côté des questions cela dit la
question était pertinente et ça réveille
beaucoup de choses aussi sur l'état
d'esprit finalement du parti et de la
jeunesse par rapport à la question
d'autorité pour ça c'est sur le climat
général
les questions étaient extrêmement
pertinentes et très précises elle était
bien préparé j'ai trouvé ça absolument
hyper intéressant donc je voulais
féliciter les jeunes qui les ont posées
et les intervenants qui ont répondu
était tout aussi intéressant alors nous
avons quatre points qui ont été abordés
le premier point qui m'a marqué c'était
un point assez critique envers la
politique de droite
enfin quand la droite était au pouvoir
finalement sur les questions de la
sécurité et de l'autorité alors c'est
intéressant aussi de voir quand on a des
jeunes dans notre parti qui arrive
malgré tout avoir un regard critique sur
notre propre action et ça aussi c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut saluer nous
avons des jeunes qui réfléchissent qui
ne suivent pas bêtement et ça c'est une
vraie fierté je pense est donc à cette
question-là bon là les réponses ont été
très pertinente et nous avons forme a
finalement retourné le faire nous avons
étudié cette question sous l'angle
finalement de la précision donc c'était
péchenard qui a répandu finalement sur
cette question
fasse finalement à la question de la du
traitement donc de la droite et la
sécurité afin de s'excuser de la
sécurité quand la droite est au pouvoir
la question se pose plus
en termes finalement de formation de
notre élite policière plutôt que sur le
nombre à proprement parler bon ça
c'était le premier point qui dénotait
par rapport au reste
ensuite nous avons trois questions plus
classiques qui ont été abordés la
première question c'est la question de
la sanction et de l'impunité le rapport
va faire le sentiment d'impunité
finalement fin rapport à la sanction
alors finalement sujet assez classique
de la droite face à laquelle donc
monsieur copé a rappelé finalement
l'intérêt et même l'importance de
développer une véritable doctrine de
rapports de forces pour sortir de cette
impasse
voilà donc ça c'est la question très
central est très classique finalement de
la sanction deuxième point intéressant
justice pénale donc c'est une question
très pertinente qui a été posé sur les
questions de la justice pénale et
finalement ce besoin même ce désir de
formuler une véritable politique une
véritable pensée finalement sur les
questions de justice sociale et la
défense finalement des droits aussi des
mis en cause
question qu'on oublie quelquefois
lorsque nous sommes de l'autre côté que
nous avons plutôt tendance à évaluer
plutôt la question de la victime donc là
c'était toute une question
finalement libéral autour de la défense
finalement des droits des mis en cause
des condamnés par la suite et ensuite
dernière question absolument
intéressante la question de l'éducation
donc la place de l'éducation dans cette
autorité
la transmission des valeurs de la
verticalité que ce soit dans la famille
ou bien à l'école donc socialisation
primaire au secondaire la question
finalement de cette transmission des
valeurs de la république qui ne se fait
pas de la même manière et de manière
tout à fait moi j'aime dans tous les
foyers de cette france donc c'est la
question sur laquelle nous avons terminé
me semble et qui était absolument des
raisons voilà c'était juste une
restitution des points qui ont été
abordés et bas sans surprise nous aurons
nous avons tourné autour des mêmes
questions de manière assez récurrente
est ce qui est tout à fait normal
puisque nous jeunesse de france nous
avons besoin finalement surtout à droite
d'avoir des solutions et même des
réponses à ces questions que nous nous
posons perpétuellement bon c'était
tellement bien résumé que je ne
relancerait pas marie est parfaitement
résumée cher valentin alors dans le
prolongement de ce qui évoquait
d'ailleurs marie à l'instant au delà de
l'autorité de la démocratie c'est la
question fondamentale de la république
et des réussites lier à la république
c'est ce qu'ils font de nous notre
engagement
je pense à tous ici c'est que nous
sommes de droite parce que nous
considérons que la droite c'est le grand
mouvement de l'égalité des chances de
l'ascenseur social et qui permet à ceux
par leur travail par leur talent parle
aux vocations un jour de devenir
quelqu'un
alors qu'est ce que tu as retenu de
cette table ronde toi alors déjà j'ai
retenu que les échanges avaient été très
les interventions a été très fructueuse
et moi ce qui m'a frappé déjà c'est
qu'ils avaient beaucoup de témoignages
donc beaucoup de gens ont raconté leur
expérience justement face à au manque de
moyens qui avait mis l'état pur pour eux
donc déjà on est parti d'un constat
c'est que
la france n'a jamais autant fracturé que
ce soit que ce soit sur les fractures
territoriales
la fracture sociale et les fractures
numériques et maniema premier produit
beaucoup de choses lors de sa campagne
présidentielle
et le constat qu'on a fait de base c'est
que très peu de choses avaient été faits
sur ces trois dernières années
ensuite on a eu un petit débat sur
qu'est-ce qui était la réussite parce
qu'au début on allait beaucoup sur la
réussite professionnelle
mais il ya aussi la réussite personnelle
qui rentrant qui rentrent en jeu et qui
rentre dans le débat et on s'est tout de
suite retourné et là la principale
question c'était la question d'éducation
d'une part on a beaucoup parlé
d'orientation pendant quasiment la
moitié du du débat sur le fait que les
facultés et ait été trop plein et plein
de plein de personnes qui en fait
n'était pas destiné à forcément à faire
un baccalauréat général
donc on a beaucoup parlé de la rivale la
revalorisation des filières
professionnelles des filières
technologiques
ensuite on sait on s'est un peu
redirigée sur justement l'apprentissage
on a beaucoup expliqué avec avec les
intervenants que
c'était la culture française de beaucoup
valoriser l'intelligence scientifique et
pas assez
l'intelligence de la main et que
notamment dans la culture germanique
on mettait beaucoup plus en valeur et
c'est aussi pour ça et c'est ce que
ronan le gleut sénateur des français de
l'étranger en allemagne a expliqué c'est
que si le chômage des jeunes en
allemagne était beaucoup plus que le
nôtre c'est aussi parce que nous s'est
passé parce que eux
mettez beaucoup plus en avant
l'intelligence de la main ensuite et il
nous expliquait d'ailleurs l'olympiade
des métiers l'olympe à des métiers qui
met justement en valeur l'intelligence
de la main et il a regretté et il a
raison que on a beaucoup d'artisans
français qui gagnent ces olympiades des
métiers tous les ans mais qu'on n'est
pas du tout en valeur et je pense qu'en
mettant en valeur ces métiers là par les
concours qu'on gagne en france sur le
territoire français on pourrait aussi
inciter les jeunes qui vont en effet
qu'il joue dès la première année
rediriger dès le collège et des lycées
vers ces métiers là et ainsi favoriser
une mixité est favorisée surtout
une réussite de leur part d'un point de
vue professionnel ensuite on s'est
arrêtés aussi sur le service militaire
qui était très intéressant
une personne a regretté le service
militaire tels qu'ils étaient même s'il
était il y avait beaucoup de la revoir
mais il faut aussi le dire c'est la
droite qui l'a supprimé et beaucoup de
jeunes ici et ça a été dit le regrette
alors peut-être qu'il a à revoir
certains voient là il est lui même le
débat de la durée ça à l'époque je crois
que ç'a duré un an si je me trompe pas
peut-être que c'est trop long mais en
tout cas à l'époque il y avait beaucoup
de valeurs qui étaient à véhiculer par
le service militaire
l'intégration aux valeurs de la
république aujourd'hui quand on voit
beaucoup de jeunes qui sortent
totalement des valeurs de la république
je peux être que le service militaire et
moi je le pense personnellement et on
était un certain nombre à le dire pour
être une réponse une solution à ce
problème là et on a eu la chance d'avoir
le témoignage d'une personne qui a
justement fait le service national
universel l'an dernier donc sur le
premier le premier test et il a regretté
deux choses
déjà deux semaines c'est beaucoup trop
court et l'autre chose qu'il a regretté
sais que ça va vraiment un aspect
colonie de vacances voilà donc ce
témoignage était intéressant justement
pour pour débattre sur sur ce service
militaire service civique sur service
national universel comme comme il aime à
temps
ensuite on a beaucoup parlé de la
fracture territoriale la question de la
ruralité beaucoup de territoires
beaucoup trop enclavées et notamment sur
la question du numérique
donc on a fait le coup on n'avait retenu
que emmanuel macron en 2007 avait promis
le très haut débit partout
or rien n'a été fait et donc beaucoup de
jeunes des territoires se sont plaints
de ce sont plein de saray il ya
énormément de zones blanches et c'est là
où on a
ou daniel fasquelle nous expliquer avec
ses valeurs gaullistes qui lui sont
propres et qui nous attache aussi
beaucoup qu'à l'époque on n'avait pas
fait assez pour n'avait pas assez fait
sur le numérique sur le haut débit et
qu'on manquait et il a fait le constat
aussi con manquer énormément de moyens
d'investissement sur ce sur ce sujet là
parce que nos dépenses de fonctionnement
de l'état et évidemment beaucoup trop
beaucoup trop lourde et ça on le dit
depuis depuis des années ensuite on
s'est un peu égaré ringard et non mais
sur le désarmer 10 sur les déserts
médicaux
et pareil on a eu le constat dans le
témoignage d'un étudiant en médecine qui
avait qui pour convaincre qu'on avait
redirigé vers une licence qui était
beaucoup plus loin de son territoire
d'origine alors qu'il avait une
université beaucoup plus proche de chez
lui
donc une fois plus il ya les territoires
il ya des territoires qui sont pas assez
mise en valeur en france
ensuite on sait on s'est arrêté sur les
universités sur le manque de mobilité
dans les universités on a parlé de
d'erasmus aussi erasmus pro et
ensuite on a eu on a vu des personnes
qui ont voulu intervenir sur l'esprit
d'entreprendre que notamment ne véhicule
pas assez dans les universités le fait
qu'ils passaient de lien entre
l'entreprise et l'apprentissage
académique dans les universités et
ensuite donc sur l'esprit d'entreprendre
il ya eu il ya des gens qui se sont
plaints que même s'il y avait beaucoup d
aide beaucoup de réduction de charges
pour les jeunes entrepreneurs
il y avait un manque d'accompagnement et
et ils moi ce que j'ai constaté de façon
générale dans cet atelier c'est qu'à
aucun moment on a parlé d' aide
on a parlé d'être financière on a
beaucoup parlé d' accompagnement et
c'est aussi ça je pense la droite et
c'est la droite que qu'il faut qu'on
qu'on la droite il faut qu'on porte
c'est aussi non à l'assistanat mais il y
avait aussi beaucoup de
[Musique]
on a envie et les jeunes ont envie
surtout qu'on leur donne les clés alors
voilà qu'on leur ouvre pas la porte mais
qu'on leur donne les clés les clés de
réussir donc à aucun moment on a parlé
d' aide
c'est ça aussi qui m'a qui m'a un peu
marqué c'est que les jeunes ils ont
envie aussi qu'on leur donne des moyens
mais pas pour l'heure mais pas qu'on
fasse à leur place et c'est aussi ce qui
m'a beaucoup marqué et je pense que
c'est vraiment l'une des valeurs qu'on
doit porter pour les prochaines séances
c'est vraiment la méritocratie
républicaine très bien résumé très belle
conclusion à l'entente trèbes remarque
région atwani d'assistanat mais un
accompagnement de tout à fait ça alors
le quatrième atelier
qui n'était pas le plus facile
réconcilier europe et souveraineté et
ses hélices qui va en faire le rapport
le sujet européen est devenu un sujet
national la crise migratoire le bric
site les récentes élections européennes
ont mis le sujet européen vraiment au
rang des priorités nationales ou en tout
cas des sujets les plus débattus au plan
national
alors inutile de se masquer de se voiler
la face
l'europe fait l'objet oui c'est vrai il
ya une réelle désaffection à l'égard de
l'europe et cette désaffection ils
procèdent largement de l'affaiblissement
des noises des nations et de la perte de
souveraineté c'était précisément le
sujet auquel vous étiez invité à
réfléchir
j'aurais vous rapporter une anecdote il
ya quelques temps je débattais sur un
plateau de télévision avec un vieux
socialiste nommé webber qui est mort
récemment
et c'était vraiment un socialiste
acharnée pour lequel à l'image de
mitterrand son maître à penser
les nations s'est-elle nationalisme et
pour mitterrand le nationalisme c'était
la guerre dont vous voyez le raccourci
il était interdit de prononcer même le
nos deux nations
et quelle ne fut pas ma surprise lorsque
ce monsieur weber dont j'ai oublié le
prénom henri henri weber reconnue sur ce
plateau de télévision que la grande
erreur de la gauche avait était
l'impensé des nations l'impensé délation
et que ce socialiste qui avait
accompagné précisément toutes les étapes
de la dilution de la nation le
reconnaissent ainsi devant tout le monde
m'a paru être un signe vraiment
particulièrement éloquent mais c'était
vraiment l'aveu de l'échec
l'impensé v nations or je crois que
depuis ces dernières années on a vu
revenir en grâce
les nations ce n'est plus indécent de
parler de la nation et je crois que ce
n'est pas incompatible
évidemment avec l'europe telle que en
tout cas le conçoivent les républicains
donc élise à toi la parole pour la
restitution de cet atelier
merci évidemment je pense comme les
compagnons 1h30 c'est beaucoup trop
court pour un sujet aussi vaste que ce
soit l'europe et les souverainetés on
peut également parler de la souveraineté
au singulier
qu'est ce que la souveraineté finalement
c'est une question qu'on s'est posée est
l'exercice le privilège d'exercer la
compétence de sa compétence
l'europe veut dire on a aussi beaucoup
posé de questions fin du questionnement
sur tous les sujets vraiment que ce soit
même l'alimentation souveraineté
alimentaire ça recouvre vraiment tout et
nous avons abordé la question de
l'immigration notamment schengen est-ce
que
schengen fonctionne encore on a pu
conclure que finalement schengen ne
fonctionnait enfin fonctionner bien ce
qui pouvait ne pas fonctionner c'était
les frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne qui ne font pas forcément un
consensus au sein des états membres
nous avons également abordé la question
économique avec les politiques
commerciales et industrielles
est ce qui ne serait pas mieux de mettre
en place une sorte de préférence
européenne
quand on constate aujourd'hui que 95%
des marchés publics européens sont
dirigés vers l'étranger on peut
également soulevé la question c'est que
europe et souveraineté faisant de deux
manières l'union européenne en tant
qu'ensemble avec ses états membres face
au reste du monde et les états membres
face à l'europe il certains
dysfonctionnements peuvent être causés
d'un point de vue interne union
européenne l interne regard des
institutions est ce que les institutions
sont on va dire conçu de manière à
mettre les états membres d'accord sur un
stand de questions est ce qu'il faudrait
revoir aussi le système de l'unanimité
et pour conclure je pense que l'union
européenne exerce ses pouvoirs et donc
sa souveraineté cependant cette
puissance est partagée avec les états
membres ce qui peut parfois poser un
petit conflit et les jeunes ont un rôle
à jouer aussi dans l'union européenne
c'est à nous de savoir quelle europe
nous souhaitons nous souhaitons avoir
simplement
et voilà
[Applaudissements]
voilà bien écouter cette séquence
s'achève merci à nos quatre valeureux
rapporteur et puis voilà je vous
renouvelle tous nos remerciements et
notre secrétaire général rappelle
peut-être nous parler de la suite des
festivités je me glisse entre vous pour
d'abord pour vous remercier toutes et
tous pour l'exercice qui n'était pas
simple vous inviter à la suite des
séquences on vous propose de sortir à
l'extérieur vous avez quelques temps de
détente donc les terrains de foot qui
vous attendent des terrains de pétanque
pour les moins sportifs de nos tous
l'apéro ne commence qu'à 19 heures pour
les encore moins sportifs de nous tous
et vous avez aussi je vous invite à
aller les saluer et à prendre du temps
avec eux dans l'est dans le jardin sur
la pelouse
une association de graffeurs qui prépare
une fresque sur la république et qui
sera demain totalement finalisé prenez
du temps pour échanger avec eux pour
participer avec eux à cette séquence là
on se retrouve à 19 heures pour
l'apéritif une petite consignes
techniques pour ceux qui n'ont pas
récupéré leur clé de chambre d'hôtel
c'est ça que maintenant et dire
extrêmement discipliné je répète ce
qu'on vous demande de dire allez
récupérer vos clés de chambres d'hôtel
sinon vous serez condamné à dormir avec
quelqu'un d'autre
ostende hébergement voilà merci à toutes
et à tous on vous retrouve dehors
pendant une grosse demi heure